bonjour je suis Jamie Gourmaud
journaliste plutôt journaliste
scientifique et je vais réagir aux
archives de Lina
bonjour Jamie bonjour Hugo alors vous
avez mis votre vie au service de la
science on va commencer par c'est pas
sorcier pendant 21 ans 21 ans vous avez
parlé à plusieurs générations dans ce
célèbre camion on parle donc d'une
émission légendaire
[Musique]
ça vous étonne peut-être mais le son
savoyage ça circule et si vous regardez
bien vous pouvez même le voir passer
n'est-ce pas Jamy exact nous ouvrez bien
les yeux quand même parce que le son ça
se promène pas en agitant les bras comme
ça pour dire bonjour pour le voir passer
vous prenez tout simplement une boîte à
gâteaux vous enlevez le couvercle vous
le remplacez par une feuille de
plastique que vous maintenez avec un
élastique vous prenez des billes de
polystyrène vous les posez sur le
plastique vous tapez dans le couvercle
ça bouge et c'est normal le son c'est
quoi c'est une vibration quand je tape
sur mon couvercle et bien ils vibrent il
fait vibrer l'air les molécules d'air
qui viennent cogner contre ma feuille de
plastique qui fait bouger mes billes de
polystyrène quand je parle c'est
exactement la même chose
premier c'est pas sorcier voilà ça c'est
en 1994 septembre 1994 c'est vraiment
une expérience une démonstration
qui a énormément compté dans mon
appétence pour la science parce que
quand je me suis posé la question au
tout départ qu'est-ce que c'est que le
son j'étais allé interroger plusieurs
ingénieurs du son aucun arrivée à me
donner une définition concrète
conceptualisable de ce qui était le son
je me suis retrouvé en contact avec un
ingénieur de l'Ircam qui m'a emmené dans
un labo il y avait deux énormes timbales
il en a il a fait exactement la même
expérience que celle que je suis en
train de faire là mais avec des timbales
donc il a déposé des bits de polystyrène
sur une des timbales et puis on était à
côté d'une autre et puis il a tapé sur
la timbale à côté de laquelle nous
étions et puis on a vu donc les billes
de polystyrène il m'a expliqué que
vraiment le son c'était une vibration de
l'air qui vibre c'est mécanique si on
avait la possibilité de de
visualiser les molécules qui
constituaient et bien on les aurait vu
vibrer on aurait vu cette vibration se
transmettre de proche en proche jusqu'à
l'autre moment et d'un seul coup j'ai
compris que des principes des phénomènes
qui sont très difficiles à comprendre et
bien suite trouver les bons mots les
bonnes images pour que d'un seul quid
devienne conceptualisables et que
l'invisible
devienne compréhensibles et palpable et
à partir de là je me suis dit je peux
tout expliquer oui donc si je comprends
bien en fait c'est un peu une soif
d'apprendre une soif de transmettre qui
vous a donné envie de faire ça moi j'ai
plutôt au départ choisi une carrière
littéraire mais que j'ai fini par parler
de science mais les deux sont d'une
incroyable compatibilité parce qu'il se
trouve que j'adore les j'adore écrire
mais que pour parler de science et pour
décrire la science pour la raconter il
faut utiliser les bons mots pourquoi il
y a ce faussé aujourd'hui entre la
population le public et la science
pourquoi il y a ce des amours pourquoi
on dit que si Français sur 10 pense que
la science apporte autant de
désagréments que de bien-être mais parce
que justement on n'a pas su faire aimer
la science et pour faire aimeration
c'est bien il faut bien la dire bien la
raconter il faut en faire un objet de
culture générale et pour cela et bien il
faut trouver les mots justes prendre le
temps de l'expliquer de la mettre en
scène comme on met toutes les autres
disciplines culturelles en scène il faut
faire la même chose avec la science
[Musique]
et d'être soulagé
ouais c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui c'est
c'est assez
déroutant mais bon ce sont des images en
noir et blanc qui date de 1959 donc
évidemment
aujourd'hui non seulement on ne
montrerait plus mais je pense que ce
type de manip ne se font même plus sur
sur l'animal cette émission ce qui est
très caractéristique c'est que on est
dans un vrai laboratoire on est avec un
scientifique qui voulait remarqué est en
blouse blanche
il est grand beaucoup plus grand que le
le présentateur et il a une façon de
s'exprimer qui qui toise le présentateur
et on voit bien que le présentateur
est là pour boire les paroles du
scientifique qui est en train de
s'exprimer pour constater les choses et
pas forcément pour les expliquer
qu'est-ce que vous pensez globalement de
l'utilisation des animaux dans la
science ma réponse elle est elle est
d'une évidence moins
en utilisera les animaux pour tester
mieux ce sera mais dans certains cas et
jusqu'à certaines extrémités et bien on
est obligé d'avoir recours à l'animal
parler tout à l'heure des précurseurs de
la vulgarisation on va vous en montrer
deux deux ovnis qui sont arrivés à la
télévision dans les années 70 et qui
avec leur émission tant x on crever
l'écran pendant 10 ans imaginons qu'il
nous soit possible de voyager dans
l'espace des toiles en étoile jusqu'au
confins de l'univers et d'y rencontrer
des civilisations extraterrestres celles
qui peuplent les autres monde imaginons
aussi
en toute notes par des robots et que des
cerveaux électroniques d'une incroyable
puissance résolve à notre place les
problèmes les plus complexes imaginons
enfin que nous ayons maîtrisé le
problème du vieillissement et de la mort
que nous ayons aussi développé en nous
des super pouvoirs qui feraient de nous
ce qu'on appelle des surhommes tout cela
aujourd'hui c'est encore de la
science-fiction mais c'est aussi
peut-être la réalité de demain
[Musique]
je me souviens pas de ce numéro mais
j'en ai regardé pas mal je préfère les
considérer non pas comme des
scientifiques mais comme des personnes
qui avaient une grande culture
scientifique
Igor et
quand même eu ce mérite
de nous faire rêver c'est vrai qu'ils ne
propulsait dans des univers qui était
très très très lointain leur démarche
n'était pas de faire de la pédagogie
mais ne nous inviter à rêver à imaginer
des mondes à palpable l'objectif n'était
pas de nous expliquer le présent mais
plutôt le futur vers lequel
nos descendants pourraient aller mais
est-ce que du coup c'était pas plus une
émission de divertissement finalement
qu'une émission véritablement
scientifique je pense je pense que
c'était du divertissement
scientifique on va vous montrer
maintenant un autre précurseur de la
vulgarisation de la science un homme qui
vous a beaucoup inspiré on l'écoute sur
TF1 en 1976 l'idée de trois professeurs
d’hc c'est de mettre au point une
nouvelle fixation de sécurité qui allie
à la fois la finesse de l'électronique
et la rapidité d'une explosion chimique
voici comment ça se passe sur un modèle
qui est actuellement en cours d'essai
ici même dans ce laboratoire de l'École
des Arts et Métiers à Paris ceci ça
reproduit la semelle de la chaussure en
dessous cette planche de bois bien sûr
c'est le ski là dans cette fixation se
trouve les capteurs électroniques
regardez j'applique un effort je fais
une chute de ski
voilà le système fonctionne répond au
millième de seconde près voilà donc la
grande nouveauté en matière de fixation
de sécurité
mais là c'est
c'est génial
Michel Chevalet mais là la démarche est
totalement différente on voit bien que
ce que fait Michel Chevalet là c'est il
est devant un support une maquette et il
est en train de décrire un phénomène il
est dans dans l'explication dans la dans
la pédagogie c'est marrant parce que il
décrit donc une fixation de ski qui
n'existe pas au moment où il en parle
qui existera et qui depuis est dépassé
donc lui aussi il parle un petit peu
d'avenir de ce qui va se passer mais
mais il a un vrai support voilà et la
démarche est totalement totalement
différente si on parlait d'un homme qui
comme vous aimez bien les maquettes
aussi j'ai grandi dans une famille où on
regardait le le journal de 20h le soir
c'était une
une sorte de grand-messe à laquelle
on ne pouvait pas ne pas assister on
pouvait pas se dérober et je me souviens
d'avoir regardé de nombreuses fois
Michel Chevalet je suis persuadé que
sans le vouloir
sa façon de faire c'est un script
quelque part dans ma mémoire et que ça
rejaillit d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai
toujours dit que nous n'étions pas des
créateurs nous ne sommes que des
héritiers et moi je ne suis que
l'héritier de toutes les personnes que
vous m'avez présenté alors Jamil la
science n'est pas toujours cru il faut
croire qu'elle ne l'est pas par une
communauté de personnes une communauté
qui prend une certaine ampleur sur les
réseaux sociaux on part aux États-Unis
en 2020 Travis Finley fait partie de la
communauté platiste
il commente en direct sur sa chaîne
Youtube c'est relever du jour à ses
abonnés pour lui la terre ne serait pas
ronde ne tournerait pas autour du soleil
ni sur son axe
globe si la terre est un globe il y a
des gens qui se retrouvent la tête en
bas comment des gens peuvent-ils vivre
la tête en bas parce qu'il y a la
gravité
[Musique]
voici le monde selon les platistes la
terre serait horizontale le Pôle Nord au
milieu l'Antarctique constituerait le
bord extérieur et au-delà ce serait le
gouffre
les platistes ont leur convention
annuelles sur leur t-shirts le logo de
la NASA est détourné en menteur pour eux
la conquête spatiale serait un complot
destiné à soutirer l'argent des
contribuables non non on n'est jamais
allé dans l'espace on envoie des fusées
oui mais il y a personne dedans
ça me ça me laisse sans voix c'est cette
histoire de de terre plate
on pourrait revenir et détailler quand
on répond à ce monsieur
bah si il y a la gravité et qu'il dit
oui c'est ce qu'on nous raconte bah non
la gravité c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
raconte c'est quelque chose qui
s'explique si la terre était plate et
que malgré tout ce monsieur tient debout
ça veut dire qu'il y a quelque chose qui
qui va l'attirer vers le centre de de
cette terre et que donc plus il
s'éloignerait de ce centre moins il
serait vertical et donc il s'inclinerait
voilà et il y a des choses qui qui
nécessitent une explication qui
nécessite une démonstration et leur
modèle ne tient pas on sent que ça vous
énerve quand même ce sujet oui ça
m'énerve parce qu'on perd du temps si
vous voulez le temps que l'on passe à
parler de ce sujet c'est du temps que
l'on ne passe pas à expliquer d'autre
chose pendant le temps que l'on ne passe
pas à expliquer le reste et bien la
science avance et le fossé entre la
science et la société se creuse c'est
comme si je vous disais à plus un ça
fait deux tout le monde est d'accord et
sauf que ils disent non on n'est pas
d'accord et qu'à un moment donné on est
à court d'arguments donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait est-ce qu'on continue à reproduire
éternellement la même démonstration face
à des gens qui vont éternellement
refuser cette démonstration ou est-ce
qu'on passe à autre chose
alors est-ce que le mot croire peut
fonctionner avec le mot science c'est
une très bonne question et on vous
montre un homme Albert Jacquard qui
avait une réponse assez arrêtée sur le
sujet Comment vous chercheur
scientifique arrivez-vous à concilier
vos croyances et d'ailleurs quels sont
les vôtres avec la science en d'autres
termes Dieu pour vous est-il compatible
avec la science
je me pose même pas la question non je
crois que je n'ai pas de croyance parce
que la science nous apprend à ne pas
croire et nous apprend à regarder à
savoir que ce que l'on voit n'est jamais
qu'illusion à essayer d'expliquer ce qui
se passe dans ce que l'on voit de
comprendre que les modèles explicatifs
sont toujours à réviser par conséquent
la science ne croit à rien le
scientifique ne croit pas il constate il
compare il vérifie de tout on ne croit
pas en la science c'est le mot croyance
et science c'est deux mots qui ne vont
pas ensemble dire que la science n'a pas
besoin de croire
la science s'appuie sur des données et
pas sur une croyance la croyance c'est
autre chose on peut être scientifique et
j'en connais on peut être scientifique
et croire
en Dieu en autre chose et vous alors ça
c'est une question tout à fait
personnelle voilà et que que je garde
pour moi
peu de gens le savent mais avant d'être
un journaliste scientifique vous avez
été journaliste reporter dans tout autre
genre on va regarder votre premier scoop
c'est un reportage sur les enfants qu'on
disait irrécupérable de Roumanie pour
lequel vous avez reçu un prix le prix du
festival du scoop danger attention les
images sont sensibles notre reporter a
pu pénétrer dans des centres interdits à
toute personne étrangères et pour cause
il a découvert l'insoutenable et
l'inadmissible des enfants en sursis
reporters Jamy Gourmaud
ses enfants ont été filmés à vider les à
une centaine de kilomètres au sud de
Bucarest derrière les murs de ce que les
Roumains ont baptisé centre dit
récupérables avant d'arriver ici ils ont
parcouru des centaines de kilomètres
ballottées d'un centrale autre triés
comme une vulgaire marchandise vider les
constituent en effet le dernier maillon
d'une chaîne infernale une sorte de
point de non-retour où les enfants
croupissent dans des conditions qu'on
nous appelle imaginés
c'est la première fois que je revois ces
images
je
m'en souviens très très bien c'était
très très dur bon parce que ça ce sont
les images
qui ont été diffusées il y en a qui
étaient encore encore plus dur mais
sorte de machine infernale qui avait été
mise en place par le régime de churchu
qui consistait évidemment à éliminer les
enfants
qui avaient soit des problèmes
psychiques ou des problèmes physiques
tout simplement parce que cette époque
en Roumanie l'avortement était interdit
tous les moyens de contraception étaient
interdits j'avais découvert
un réseau qui permettait à des familles
de ce
débarrasser d'enfants les mots sont durs
de telle sorte quatre minutes
strativement
ça ne posait aucun problème il suffit
juste simplement de considérer qu'un
enfant était comme vous l'avez dit
irrécupérable pour l'anecdote je me
souviens d'être arrivé quand je suis
quand j'ai découvert ce dernier ce
dernier site vider les je demande où
était l'hôpital des enfants et
dans les rues on me dit non il n'y a pas
d'hôpital d'enfants ici et puis à un
moment je prononce le mot de
d'irrécupérable ni récupérabili en
roumain et là je vois la le visage de la
dame qui s'éclaire ah les irrécupérables
c'est là-bas
et est-ce que vous étiez fait pour ce
genre de reportage
est-ce que vous avez aimé les faire
j'aimais beaucoup faire ce genre de
reportage quand c'est pas sorcier a vu
le jour j'allais être papa et donc quand
on a créé l'émission C'est pas sorcier
avec Fred j'avais envie de faire une
pause une pause de deux trois ans et
puis ensuite de reprendre ma caméra et
de repartir tourner là où les sujets
m'emmèneraient mais j'étais loin
d'imaginer que que c'est pas sorcier
remporterait le succès
que cette émission a remporté et que ça
durait pendant une vingtaine d'années
on arrive maintenant à la fin de
l'émission On va vous demander de
choisir la personne qui va vous poser
une question entre Laura de l'air
Thierry Ardisson Henri Chapier et Denise
Glaser
je Thierry Ardisson est-ce que vous
croyez au voyage dans le temps
non pas aujourd'hui je ne crois pas au
voyage dans le temps voilà est-ce qu'on
a besoin de voyager dans le temps quand
on a notre disposition un outil
merveilleux qui est le livre
un livre permet de voyager dans le temps
permet de retourner dans le temps ou de
se propulser vers le futur quand on lit
et qu'on imagine que le conceptualise et
bien on est déjà dans un autre monde
merci Jamy je vous en prie merci
beaucoup
[Musique]